[Música]
la situación es cada vez más inestable
en el aeropuerto de kabul donde un
tiroteo dejó un soldado afgano muerto
aunque yo bailé en mostró flexibilidad
sobre la fecha final de salida de las
tropas estadounidenses el talibán
aseguró que no aceptará una extensión
lado ms dice que no puede llevar
suministros al país y unicef advirtió
que millones de niños necesitan ayuda
humanitaria
tras tocar tierra henri se degradó a
depresión tropical el domingo en la
noche dejando sin embargo zonas anegadas
en el noreste de eeuu y miles de hogares
es sin servicio eléctrico en el sur del
país en el estado de tennessee también
afectado por inundaciones se registran
al menos 21 muertos
y la ministra francesa del deporte
calificó como un insulto para el fútbol
los hechos registrados en el partido
entre el niza y el marsella aficionados
del niza invadieron el campo luego de
lanzar botellas a los jugadores y que
uno de ellos la devolviera a la tribuna
los equipos fueron citados a una
audiencia disciplinaria
un cordial saludo mi nombre es ángela
gómez y aquí comienzan las noticias de
france 24 iniciamos el informativo en
afganistán en las últimas horas se
presentó un tiroteo en el aeropuerto de
kabul un guardia afgano perdió la vida y
otros 13 resultaron heridos las
tensiones van en aumento en la terminal
aérea ante las amenazas de atentados del
grupo terrorista estado islámico que
eeuu considera reales y cuando se acerca
el 31 de agosto fecha en la que el país
debería completar su retirada del
territorio afgano miles de afganos y
extranjeros siguen esperando a las
afueras de las pistas con la esperanza
de ser evacuados y aunque el presidente
de eeuu joe biden el no descarta llevar
a la evacuación más allá de agosto el
talibanes dijo que no permitirá una
extensión del plazo los insurgentes
entretanto recuperaron el control de
tres distritos que habían caído en
dominio de milicias locales por su parte
la o ms dijo que tiene varadas 500
toneladas de suministros para los
afganos las ayudas no pueden llegar al
territorio por las restricciones del
aeropuerto de kabul finalmente unirse
advirtió que al menos 10 millones de
niños requieren ayuda humanitaria
ante el temor por el regreso de un
régimen islámico extremista con la
llegada del talibán al poder miles de
afganos lo han dejado todo para irse a
países que les han abierto las puertas
andrew amaya nos cuenta
el regreso al poder del grupo talibán en
afganistán ha despertado temor por la
implementación de una versión extrema de
la ley islámica cientos de afganos han
llegado al aeropuerto de la capital en
un intento por huir del país en algunos
de los vuelos de evacuación el fin de
semana un grupo de familias afganas
logró llegar a las afueras de washington
funcionarios estadounidenses aseguraron
que tres bases militares están listas
para albergar hasta 22 mil afganos por
su parte reino unido espera recibir unos
20.000 de ellos aunque no aseguran que
logren evacuar a todos absolutamente
nadie lamentablemente puede decir frente
a una cámara de televisión que podremos
evacuar los a todos la dura realidad de
situaciones complejas caóticas y
peligrosas como esta es que puede que
simplemente este no sea el caso
canadá se ha sumado al plan dando
prioridad a las minorías y personas de
la comunidad lgbt
representantes de la unión europea
visitaron el fin de semana junto con el
presidente del gobierno español un
centro que recibirá a refugiados afganos
con capacidad para mil personas la
estadía será temporal ya que luego serán
enviados a diferentes países del bloque
comunitario decenas de ellos ya han
llegado a francia y alemania- en américa
latina los gobiernos de brasil chile
costa rica méxico y colombia también han
abierto sus puertas
[Música]
ante el temor de una ola migratoria
proveniente de afganistán
grecia construyó una valla fronteriza
con turquía de 40 kilómetros de largo lo
mismo hizo ankara que levantó un muro en
su frontera con irán con el fin de
evitar el paso de los migrantes
la vicepresidenta de eeuu kamala harris
se dijo que habrá mucho tiempo más
adelante para analizar los eventos de
afganistán pero que la prioridad actual
es evacuar estadounidenses y afganos
vulnerables hablo desde singapur donde
avanza su tour diplomático por asia
harris ofreció una conferencia de prensa
conjunta con el primer ministro lee
hsien loong y reafirmó el compromiso de
washington de trabajar con socios y
aliados en un orden internacional sobre
el disputado mar de china meridional uno
de muchos focos de tensión entre china y
eeuu
creo que habrá mucho tiempo para
analizar lo que ocurrió y lo que ha
ocurrido en el contexto del retiro de
afganistán
pero en este momento estamos totalmente
enfocados en evacuar a los ciudadanos
estadounidenses a los afganos que
trabajaron con nosotros y a los afganos
que son vulnerables incluyendo mujeres y
niños
paula ese es nuestro enfoque particular
en este momento
y en eeuu henry se debilitó a una
depresión tropical tras tocar tierra
cerca de road atlanta pero mantendrá
fuertes lluvias en el noroeste del país
hasta hoy en la noche provocando
inundaciones repentinas y cortes de
energía entretanto en el sur de la
nación al menos 21 personas fallecieron
y 50 más siguen desaparecidas por las
lluvias e inundaciones que se
registraron este fin de semana en el
estado de tennessee la mayoría de las
víctimas son bebés y adultos mayores se
trata de las peores inundaciones
registradas en el estado en tres décadas
a de usted
hubo un récord de los centímetros de
lluvia que cayeron entre la noche del
viernes y la mañana del sábado que
crearon una devastadora inundación en
esta comunidad tercer informe describir
es una tremenda pérdida de vidas varios
desaparecidos en terreno casas
desvanecidas vehículos que fueron
arrastrados en la comunidad es un
panorama devastador de pérdida y dolor
del corazón
hoy es el aniversario de la insurrección
de los hombres y mujeres sometidos a la
esclavitud en sant dominique en la parte
occidental de la isla de la española que
hoy conocemos como haití a partir de
estos hechos se conmemora el día
internacional del recuerdo de la trata
de esclavos y la abolición de la
esclavitud maría elisa velázquez
gutiérrez doctora en historia y ex
presidenta del comité científico
internacional de la ruta del esclavo de
la unesco nos explicó cómo en 2021
persisten formas de esclavitud y cuáles
son los focos rojos de trata de personas
en américa latina
existen existen en varias partes del
mundo muchas veces no de manera
explícita no abiertamente pero las
formas de sumisión de horarios de formas
de pago son claramente formas de
esclavitud contemporáneas muchos países
la seguimos
los viviendo y bueno es muy triste y muy
lamentable que siga sucediendo bueno la
trata de personas se da en varios países
de américa latina tiene que ver con
redes extensas de comercio que van
por distintos países hasta eeuu y muchos
de ellos hacia europa
la unesco tiene un proyecto que también
se preocupa por este tema pero digamos
el que se ha ocupado de dar a conocer
esta fecha y su importancia ha sido el
proyecto internacional la ruta del
esclavo
libertad patrimonio y resistencia
finalmente en francia la ministra de
deporte de roxana amarís en menudo
advirtió de sanciones después de los
incidentes de este domingo en el estado
de niza que se enfrentó al olympique de
marsella varios hinchas del conjunto
local invadieron el campo y se
enfrentaron a los jugadores del cuadro
visitante antes la estrella del marsella
dmitri pelea había respondido a la grada
devolviendo una de las varias botellas
que le habían lanzado durante todo el
encuentro era el minuto 74 del partido
que en ese momento transcurría con una
victoria parcial para el niza el duelo
fue suspendido y la fiscalía abrió una
investigación en torno a los hechos
además ambos clubes fueron citados para
una audiencia disciplinaria
y la liga decidió no retomar el partido
y nosotros decidimos por la seguridad de
nuestros jugadores que fueron atacados
durante la invasión de campo no volver
porque la seguridad de nuestros
jugadores no estaba garantizada se
pagaban ti
desafortunadamente lo que prendió la
mecha fue la reacción de dos jugadores
del marsella que lanzaron botellas a los
aficionados a partir de ahí todo se
desencadenó
en nuestros titulares a esta hora en
france 24 punto como usted puede
encontrar la actualización de nuestras
noticias se ve a haití bandas armadas
anuncio en tregua para permitir la
llegada de ayuda humanitaria y a una
semana del terremoto la gravedad de la
crisis humanitaria en el país aumenta
y así llegamos al final del informativo
recuerde seguirnos y volvemos más
adelante buenos días
[Música]